дуже цікаво було би почути позицію
заступника голови комітету з питань
фінансів пана дубінського нам СБУ
говорить що він буратіна Агент значить
там російський До речі нагадаю це слуга
народу якого обрали сюди слуга народу
їхні очільник Київської обласної
організації партії але він в нас ще і
заступник голови фінансового комітету в
парламенті Так ви там визначитесь він
буротіна чи заступник голови фінансового
комітету в Верховній Раді бо це якось
разом не скла дається Бо як на мене це
дивна історія Хто папа Карла хто там
Мальвіна хто арлікін хто як його
приводив до влади цього як вим нам зараз
кажуть що це буратіна оце Хотілося би
почути ж Хотілося би нам щоб ми якось
визначилися і наші колеги зі слуги
народу теж визначилися і не робили
вигляд що вони до цього буратіна як вони
його тепер називають не мають жодного
відношення Ні друзі це ви папа Карла
який цього буратіна створив якщо він
вправду буратіна і привели його в
Верховну Раду